you
in today's morning rounds were focusing
on CBD do you know what that is the
compound that's popping up in everything
from food to beauty products CBD which
comes from plants in the cannabis family
has been marketed as a solution for
anxiety pain in epilepsy - with
Walgreens and CVS expanding into hemp
hemp derived CBD products the FDA is
taking a closer look at the unregulated
market outgoing FDA Commissioner dr.
Scott Gottlieb told lawmakers the other
day he is uneasy about the drugstore
chains decisions CVS says it follows FDA
guidance the agency will hold a public
hearing next month or dr. tehrani rule
is is here to sort it out out I don't
know what are you here to do she is here
to sort it all out for us you start with
me because I always thought number one I
need a new tongue but that's another
story
but I always thought it had something to
do with marijuana I think there's a lot
of confusion that's not like me no it is
not just you so let's start with the
cannabis plant the cannabis plant has
over a hundred types of cannabinoids
these are chemical compounds the most
common two types are THC which is the
psychoactive type that you think of in
marijuana and CBD cannabidiol which does
not have abused or addictive potential
is not psychoactive we know that the
body we learned this in the 1990s has
our own endogenous cannabinoids system
we produce our own and there are
receptors spread throughout our brain
multiple organs and our immune cells so
it makes sense that these products may
have some effect on the different parts
of the body as they claim although at
this point the market is really way
beyond where the science even though
it's comes from the cannabis family
cannot get you high
no.not CBD yeah but that's really
interesting because every once in a
while with these things pop up st.
John's wort and gingko biloba and listen
to that and the other thing and so this
feels like that but what you're saying
is no this has there's actually that
with these receptors and our own ability
to produce it there is something that's
connected Nate yes I mean we learned
about this just in the 1990s oh yeah but
is there scientific evidence that it's
an effective treatment for pain or
anxiety very good question well the best
evidence thank you doctor the best
evidence comes from studies on epilepsy
so in 2018 the FDA did approve a drug
epidemic
for use in two rare syndromes of sort of
refractory seizure disorders and
children there is growing evidence for
other conditions anxiety high blood
pressure
acne diabetes but these studies are
small they've been done a lot of them in
animals and they really haven't followed
people out for a long time so we do need
more research at this point negative
side effects any so the concern that dr.
Gottlieb raised is valid which is that
we don't know what is the effect of
differing concentrations of CBD what is
the effect of cumulative exposure
chronically over a long time in addition
we know that a lot of CBD products that
are out there now are mislabeled there
was a study in 2017 that showed 70% of
CBD products on the market are wrongly
labeled they there have other things in
them they don't have the amount of CVD
they say they have in it either less or
more there's concerns about pregnant
women youth exposure also medication
interaction so for example people who
take coumadin that blood thinner if they
take CBD the coumadin levels may be
increased or interaction with
supplements so lots of questions but
generally speaking people are taking it
to relieve anxiety all kinds of things
from skin conditions to anxiety it's
it's very prevalent it's everywhere okay
thank you